from the visionary director who only
makes big visionary hits or big
ambitious disasters comes the clunky
theatrical cut of his 80s classic
improved by a director's cut ten years
later and further refined by his final
cut in 2007 we could to go Ridley sure
you don't want to go mess with the
ending again throw the voice of a rack
in and history books he's the kind of
cop used to call black men probably not
Blade Runner in 1982 audiences knew
Harrison Ford as the charming rogue Han
Solo or the charming rogue Indiana Jones
now watch him ditch the whole charming
act in the grumpiest Harrison for
performance since any time he's forced
to promote a movie this one 35 years
after the original what well I'm just
wondering one problem with that it's a
living be Deckard private dick and
public jerk with a serious drinking
problem
one drink one drink I get you a drink
drink them for me about he's a Blade
Runner part bounty hunter part awkward
psychiatrist
you're reading a magazine you come
across a full-page nude photo of a girl
suddenly realize there's a wasp crawling
on your arm the unstretched and system
oiled dog and as for why that's called a
Blade Runner shut up
it sounds cool he'll struggle with a
morality of killing things that seem to
be alive but he won't struggle with the
morality of porking them against their
will kiss me that's not how consent
works thrill as Deckard hunts robots
known as replicants soldiers and sexbots
built with false memories both aren't
your memories there's somebody else and
upgrade is cruel and pointless as giving
your fleshlight a family history and
witness the break-up performance of
Rutger Hauer a replicant who speaks in
monologues the actor wrote himself all
those moments will be lost in time like
tis and literally the only time that's
work since Apocalypse Now errand boy and
savour a film that saves its biggest
twist for last Deckard might be a
replicant - or is he maybe it's pretty
subtle and depends on the card we take
that test yourself whatever everyone
acts like a sad robot anyway get ready
to think because this slow ass movie is
gonna give you plenty of time for that
as you spend hours staring at old
photographs
staring at eyes
[Music]
and staring a Deckard staring at the
window of his car
experience a visual masterpiece that
influenced countless animes cyberpunk
films and all those times someone says
enhance at a screen over and over again
enhanced needs and hence cuz this ain't
your daddy's bright and shiny sci-fi
this one has rain and cigs and hookers
and stuff and forget about plucky rebels
fighting the evil empire this one's
about corporations making your life
short and meaningless and if that's too
dark for you at least the umbrella
sticks light up
ooh glowy so enjoy this story that sees
so clearly into the future predicting
our modern anxieties about genetic
engineering corporate ownership and
Ridley Scott's unicorn fetish that may
not have done well at the box office but
broke the all-time record for the number
of film geeks insisting it's genius all
right come on guys it looks amazing at
all but this is film noir with robots if
it was perfect
they wouldn't recut it a hundred times
starring definitely shoots first Billy
Idol Finkle is Einhorn pine or his
Finkle littering Captain Adama William
ain't may see four eyes but no eyes sex
machina and Los Angeles two years from
now huh and a nail that one
Robocop you know it's cool Harrison's
rebooting all his iconic roles but
there's not much left after Deckard how
long until we get our II witness re
regarding Henry air force to actually I
totally watch that want more Blade
Runner click the boxes to see us talk to
Harrison Ford
Brian Gosling and the rest of the cast
plus our definitive guide to both the
original movie and Blade Runner 2049
danger is my middle name
actually it's Bill I'm voice guy epic
voice guy shut up Wesley